"DEFENDING THE FIRST."
WE EXPOSE THE ENEMIES OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, FREE
EXPRESSION, AND FREE THOUGHT.
YOU ALL KNOW MICHELLE MALKIN IS
A FIERCE CHAMPION OF FREE
SPEECH, PARTICULARLY ONLINE
WHERE SHE HAS A PIONEERING
ENTREPRENEUR.
TONIGHT SHE IS GOING TO SHED
LIGHT ON THE DARK FORCES BEHIND
ORGANIZED EFFORTS TO SILENCE
CONSERVATIVES.
MICHELLE MALKIN, WELCOME BACK TO
"THE ANKLE."
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR THE PEOPLE
WATCHING FOX TONIGHT TO SEE AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS ALL IS
REALLY ALL ABOUT.
I WANT TO START WITH GEORGE
SOROS.
GEORGE SOROS HAS FUNDED
LEFT-WING GROUPS, AS YOU POINTED
OUT, THE CENTER FOR
AMERICAN PROGRESS.
I THINK WE HAVE A GRAPHIC.
THE COLOR OF CHANGE.
PEOPLE FOR THE AMERICAN WAY,
MEDIA MATTERS, ACTION NETWORK.
CONNECTED WITH MEDIA MATTERS.
THERE WE HELP ALL THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS.
TELUS, MICHELLE, WHICH ARE THE
WORST OFFENDERS AND ENEMIES OF
FREE THOUGHT AND FREE
EXPRESSION?
>> MEDIA MATTERS HAS BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THE SPEECH SQUELCH
HER'S WHO ARE HIGHLY ORGANIZED,
INCREDIBLY DISCIPLINED AND
OBVIOUSLY DEEPLY FUNDED NOT ONLY
BY GEORGE SOROS BUT A NUMBER OF
LEFT-WING FOUNDATIONS.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT SO MANY OF THESE
OUTFITS ARE TAX-EXEMPT.
THAT THEY ENJOY SO MUCH LARGESS
AS A RESULT OF IRS LOSS.
AND THAT UNDER DEMOCRATIC
ADMINISTRATIONS, THE DEFINITION
OF 5O1C3s AND FOURS HAVE BEEN
STRETCHED SO THAT THESE
BLATANTLY PARTISAN POLITICAL
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE CAST
THEMSELVES THE SOMEHOW EDUCATION
THEMSELVES THE SOMEHOW EDUCATIOL
OR SOCIAL WELFARE GROUPS.
YOU HAVE MEDIA MATTERS THAT HAVE
GONE AFTER EVERY PROMINENT
CONSERVATIVE PERSPECTIVE VOICE
IN THE PUBLIC SQUARE, THEY WILL
USE ANY PRETEXT.
THESE PEOPLE DO THIS FOR A
FULL-TIME LIVING.
AS A RESULT, IT IS UNDENIABLE,
LAURA.
WE HAVE BEEN IN THIS ARENA FOR
SO MANY YEARS IN TALK RADIO, ON
BROADCAST, AND ON SOCIAL MEDIA
WHERE IT'S BEEN SO IMPORTANT FOR
INDEPENDENT CONSERVATIVE VOICES
TO GET THEIR MESSAGES OUT.
WE KNOW THAT THE ENCROACHMENT OF
THESE SENSORS AND THESE BULLIES
IN THE PUBLIC SQUARE HAS LEFT AN
UNDENIABLE CLOUD OVER THE
FIRST AMENDMENT AND FREE
EXPRESSION.
>> Laura: MICHELLE, PEOPLE SAY
WELL, THIS IS ALL THE FREE
MARKETPLACE OF IDEAS.
EVERYONE ELSE, THEY WANT TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT SOMEONE WHO SAYS
SOMETHING, THEY DO THAT.
AND THAT'S PART OF THE
EACH SIDE HAS THEIR OWN OPINIONS
ON ONE SIDE WANTS TO BECOME A
WHATEVER THEY ARE DOING, YOU
HAVE THESE CORPORATIONS THAT GET
100 EMAILS FROM SOME LEFT-WING
ACTIVISTS.
MEANWHILE MILLIONS OF
CONSERVATIVES ARE LIKE, ARE YOU
KIDDING ME?
MAKES NO SENSE.
>> IN SOME CASES THESE
SUPPOSEDLY BACK LASH THAT
ELICITS THIS RESPONSE FROM
CORPORATIONS THAT JUST DON'T
WANT ANY BAD PUBLICITY,
SOMETIMES CONSTITUTES A COUPLE
TWEETS, RIGHT?
THEN YOU HAVE THE MEDIA MATTERS
AND COLOR OF CHANGE THAT EXPLOIT
THEIR SOCIAL JUSTICE STATUS.
THEY HAVE AN ABSOLUTE IMMUNITY
SHIELD TO GO AFTER CONSERVATIVES
FOR EXPRESSING MAINSTREAM
THOUGHT AND OPINION.
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT THE AGENDA.
THE AGENDA OF THESE LEFT-WING